الاوكرانيه اهلا بك سيد كوزان يعني
اكدت بانها باتت اليوم تتخذ مواقع دفاعيه
في عده جبهات مع احتداد هذه
الاشتباكات ما هي الاسباب اسباب عدم تحقيق
هذه العمليه المضاده التي لطالما تحدثت
عنها كياف اهدافها الاوليه
وايضا خساره الجيش الاوكراني 20% من عتاده
العسكري في الاسبوعين الاولين كما ورد من
بعض المصادر
بان نقول ان الهدف الاساسي لاي هجوم مضاد
هو تدمير قوات العدو واذا نظرنا للمدفعيه
لدى العدو وهذا الجزء الاهم في قدراته فما
الذي نراه
راجمات الصواريخ ومنظومات الدفاع الجوي
سوف يتضح لنا ان في الشهر الماضي
تدمرت اكبر احجام وكميات من هذه القدرات
العسكريه لذلك اوكرانيا تقوم بخطوات
محدده في استنزاف القوات الروسيه وعندما
نجعل قدراتهم تصل الى اقل نسبه سوف نتمكن
من التقدم والمضي في تحرير اراضينا اذا كل
شيء يسير على الخطه لكن الحديث هنا لا
يجري عن يعني ما تحرز القوات الاوكرانيه
يحدثون عن خساره القوات الاوكرانيه 20% من
عتدها
العسكري وعن تراجع للقوات الاوكرانيه كيف
نفسر ذلك مازلت لم تجبني على هذا السؤال
سيره
انها عشرين بالمئه ليست من القوه انها
ليست من القوات الاوكرانيه هذا ما تعلنه
وسائل الاعلام الغربيه عن 20% من الاسلحه
الغربيه التي تصل لاوكرانيا ولكنني اذكر
ان اغلب الاسلحه التي تستخدم في المعارك
الاوكرانيه هي اسلحه من انتاج اوكراني
لذلك نعم الاسلحه الغربيه قامت بمهمات
اساسيه ولقد قامت قواتنا بتحقيق اهداف
معينه وتستمر
بتحقيق هذه الاهداف والهدف الاساسي هو
استنزاف العدو وتدمير عدد من افراده
ومعداته وهذا هو الهدف وهذا هو الهدف
الاهم الذي وصلنا له
واجبرنا روسيا ان تستخدم قواتها
الاحتياطيه
وهذه المهمه ننجح بها بخسارات قليله جدا
لكن على الاقل يعني ما ورد من انباء حتى
الان يتحدث عن
بعض التراجع او حتى المصادر الاوكرانيه
تتحدث عن مواقع دفاعيه وليست هجوميه الان
للجيش الاوكراني الان يعني في هذه المعارك
الى اي مدى يمكن الحديث عن تاثير او تغيير
للضمانات الامنيه او ما حصلت عليه
اوكرانيا لنقل من قمه النيتو ومن تعهدات
وضمانات امنيه من مجموعه السبع في عمليتها
المضاده
اولا
وهناك تقدم بسيط
وهذا التقدم قد يكون بحدود بعض
الكيلومترات في
جبهات اخرى وهذا سدس كل الجبهات في باخموت
نحن نتقدم
والقوات الروسيه تتراجع فيزا نحن نتقدم
الروس يتراجع وفي خرسون ايضا نتقدم
والروسيه تراجعوا وفي الجنوبي من دانيسك
ايضا اذا في مارينكا
الهجم
الهجوم هناك قد تجمد طبعا القوات الروسيه
تحاول ان تظهر لوحه في مصلحتها ولكن في
الواقع استخدموا اكبر اعداد من
قواتهم ويحاولوا ان يظهر وانهم نجحوا في
بعض المهام لان الجيش الروسي قد كثرت
معنوياته تماما وفي الواقع
الاولويه
المشكله الاساسيه ان الجنرالات الروس لا
يثق في قيادتهم العسكريه وفي الجيش الروسي
هناك بدايه تمرد وعصيان ضد شيكو وضد بوتين
كما ظهر لنا يعني امام الحديد حديثه كالان
عن هذا التقدم للقوات الاوكرانيه في جبهات
عده ما الحاجه الان لاستخدام ذخائر
عنقوديه
طلبتها اوكرانيا واوصلتها اليوم واشنطن
وقد تحدث الرئيس الامريكي عن ضوء اخضر
الان باستخدامها ولوحت موسكو الان في
مشروعيتها لاستخدامها في المقابل ضد
اوكرانيا
نعم هذه حقيقه بالنسبه للقانون الاوكراني
لدينا حق ان نستخدم القذائف العنقوديه
تماما كما تقوم بهذا القوات الامريكيه او
مجموعه من الدول الاوروبيه
وطبعا تدمير المعدات
وقوات العدو هذا شيء سيكون اسهل باستخدام
القذائف العنقوديه
هذا سوف يكون افضل من استنزاف اعداد كبيره
من صواريخ باهضه الثمن لذلك حتى نستطيع ان
نقوم بضربات مؤثره نستخدم هذه القذائف
وهذا لا يخالف القوانين عدا عن ذلك هناك
اعلانات من وزير الدفاع ريزني اننا سوف
نستخدم هذه الذ
فقط في اماكن تجمع الجنود الروس اذا لن
نقوم بهجوم باستخدام القذائف العنقوديه ضد
منشاه مدنيه وهذا ما يجعلنا مختلفين مع
القوات الروسيه الذين كانوا يستخدموا
الصواريخ العنقوديه منذ 2014 ونحن نحارب
على اراضينا ونحررها
الاوكرانيه ورئيس مركز التعاون والامن
الاوكراني